you know the pressures on us are
overwhelming from wall street or our own
egos or from internal incentive
structures
or our bosses whatever it is the
pressures are overwhelming for us to
play the finite game
and so how do you stand up to massive
external pressure
courage and courage is something that
comes from relationships
you know it's external a a world famous
trapeze artist
would never attempt a brand new death
defying act for the first time without a
net
they would never do it so why do we
think that we could do something
difficult without external support too
um i've had the opportunity to meet real
heroes people who've
risked their lives to save the lives of
others with the belief that they were
gonna die
and they didn't and when asked why did
you do it they all say something similar
which is they would have done it for me
it's external and so we have to have
we have to take the time to foster and
take care of people around us to
nurture our relationships because when
we're going to be doing something
difficult when we're going to be
swimming upstream
when we're going to be innovating and
and and and doing something different
there are days we're going to doubt
ourselves there are days we're going to
get knocked on our ass
there are days that storms are going to
rise and we have to have people who say
i got your back you need to do this
we need you the world needs this keep
going
i believe in you you know um
and so courage courage comes from from
not only our willingness to do that for
others
but then their willingness to do it for
us and if we commit ourselves to a just
cause and we're willing to to do those
things then
you know the great thing is we take a
lot of people with us and
change the world for the better and
isn't that sort of the point of an
infinite life
to leave this world in better shape than
we found it to leave the companies that
we work for in better shape than when we
started
to leave our families stronger and
better capable than than
what they can do without us you know is
isn't that what it means to live an
infinite life that we can literally
literally live on beyond our own lives